[Musique]
vous savez que la bombe atomique a
explosé ce matin ben j'en ai entendu
quand j'ai vaguement et vous vous en
pensez
ah ben je perds encore un jeu tap tête
chez vous puisqu'on est pas plus bêtes
que les autres
merci madame s'il vous plaît
vous savez que la mamba 2006 a explosé
ce matin et si vous savez où elle a
explosé comme ça où exactement
huawei reggane nom et la pression ça
vous a fait la pente cette nouvelle
s'est très bien vendu on fait comme les
autres
et vous madame vous voulez rien me dire
ils avaient peur avec la bombe atomique
française a explosé ce matin
et bah tant mieux au cobra touche vous
savez qu'on a fait exploser une bombe
atomique ce que vous approuvez
oui je pense que la france a raison de
d'entrée au club atomique car il n'y a
pas de raison qu'on n'ait pas notre mot
à dire en ce qui concerne le désarmement
justement des armes thermonucléaires
madame vous savez qu'on a fait exploser
une bombe atomique ce matin willy est ce
que vous approuvez
non pas du tout je trouve qu'on ferait
bien mieux de dépenser cet argent là
pour la lutte contre le cancer où il ya
tellement lors tous les ans on sait que
c'est dangereux d'avoir en plus exposés
que cet idiot des consultants d'argent
madhav la bombe atomique française a
explosé ce pari là mais qu'est-ce que
quelle impression cela vous a fait eh
bien ma foi beaucoup de bien si c'était
pour servir l'humanité mais beaucoup de
mal si c'est au contraire pour
l'anéantir
j'espère que les hommes sont à ces
stages pour l'utiliser à des fins
pacifiques
vous savez monsieur la bombe atomique
explosé ce matin
on remplit sa part les journaux et je
constate que
la france a remporté quand même une
réussite technique et scientifique
est ce que vous savez les pays qui ont
déjà la bombe atomique
oui bien sûr lesquels américains et les
russes et les anglais bon c'est pas que
ça puisse avoir des conséquences
désastreuses pour nous je ne pense quoi
tout le monde pas n'ont pas fait pas que
cette pluie qui tombait rapport direct
avec un nom les rapports entre des
conditions météorologiques et puis la
bombe atomique sont à mon avis à tout le
monde c'est pareil à mon avis merci
[Musique]